es sind die schrecklichsten wirklich
nicht auszuhalten minuten für eltern sie
rennen hin zur schule in purer
verzweiflung mit nur einem gedanken im
herzen was ist mit meinem kind denn in
der schule erschießt ein irrer ihre
kinder massaker amoklauf an einer
grundschule in der 17.000 einwohner
stadt wie verdi in texas ja der killer
verbarrikadierte sich in der schule
seine opfer sind unschuldige kinder
hatten keine chance er tötet 19 kinder
und dann auch zwei erwachsene darunter
eva illouz eine lehrerin in der vierten
klasse wer ist der kindermörder der fast
selbst noch ein kind ist er heiß
salvador ramos l ging auf die highschool
in die wälder zu seinem geburtstag
besorgte er sich ganz legal
handfeuerwaffen und offenbar auch ein
gewehr auf seinem instagram account
posiert er mit waffen kurz vor der tat
schrieb er dort kryptischen nachrichten
an ein mädchen die die tat angekündigt
haben könnten ja was ist tot erschossen
im gefecht mit der polizei und wir
schauen noch einmal auf die bilder denn
hier sehen wir ihn hier betritt er
bewaffnet die schule es ist bisher das
einzige video von der tat laut
us-ermittlern schießt salvadors zuvor
auch auf seine großmutter in ihrer
wohnung sie ist jetzt in einem
krankenhaus untergebracht danach wo er
eben in diese schule baute auf dem weg
dorthin noch einen unfall und ging dann
mit einer schutzweste in einem rucksack
und einem gewehr in der hand zu fuß gold
die sicherheitsleute der schule
versuchte noch ihn aufzuhalten
vergeblich konnte sich drinnen
verbarrikadieren und wild um sich
schießen noch immer warten verzweifelte
eltern vor der schule können sie ihr
kind in die arme schließen oder bekommen
sie eine todesnachricht ein vater
schildert uns seine unerträgliche
ungewissheit hier passen ich frage immer
wieder nach was los ist aber niemand
sagt mir etwas niemand sagt mir
irgendwas nur einer der eltern sagte
dass möglicherweise kinder im bett das
institut festgehalten werden das hat
mich hierher gebracht und herauszufinden
was los ist
es gibt kinder sie sind noch da wo meine
tochter ist nicht nicht
und sie konnten sich nicht bei ihm
meldet sie wissen nicht wo sie ist
wie geht es ihnen
ich bin nur verwirrt und besorgten die
versuche herauszufinden wo meine kleine
ist
aber niemand hat ihnen gesagt dass es
ihr gut geht oder dass sie verletzt ist
es gibt viele verwirrte eltern die nicht
wissen wovor garcia ist das versuche ich
herauszufinden
und wer ist frau dass ihr
programm ist eine lehrerin
für uns vor ort in new value ist unser
bild reporter herbert bauernebel herbert
weißt du inzwischen genaueres zu den
part vorgesehen
stehe hier vor der rub elementary school
wo eben der amokschütze alberto ramos
dieses furchtbare massaker angerichtet
hat wie gesagt das ist der schlimmste
massaker in den usa seit dem morgen an
der grundschule in sandy hoch vor mehr
als vor ungefähr zehn jahren aber 20
kinder ums leben gekommen sind jetzt
eben 19 tote kinder im alter zwischen
sieben und elf jahren und die polizei
die hier natürlich in große stärke
aufmarschiert ist zimmer jetzt alles
zusammen versucht jedes detail hier
einzufangen das ganze protokoll auf zu
arbeiten begonnen hat diese blut hat
natürlich mit dem mit dem attentat auf
seine eigene großmutter dann fuhr
hierher zu dieser kleinen schule in
diesem kleinen ort 16.000 einwohner mit
einem pickup bot den er dann zu schrott
gefahren hat in einem graben ist dann
zur schule gelaufen offensichtlich
bewaffnet mit einem sturmgewehr mit
einer schusssicheren weste mit dem
munitions magazinen einem rucksack hat
dann ist dann eingedrungen in das
gebäude es soll angeblich hiernach ein
kurzes feuergefecht mit einem anderen
polizisten gegeben haben dann ging er in
die schule und begann das morden vom
klassenzimmer zu klassenzimmer
man muss sich das vorstellen die kinder
im alter zwischen sieben und elf jahren
wahrscheinlich völlig wehrlos
ausgeliefert diese waffen diese
sturmgewehre die hier verwendet werden
haben teilweise munition die große
löcher schlägt natürlich bei so kleinen
körpern unfassbare verletzungen
hervorrufen wie gesagt auch zwei lehrer
lehrerinnen sind ums leben gekommen
dann jedoch eine doch eine heldentat ein
beamter der border patrol habe nicht
gewartet auf weitere verstärkung ist
hinein in das gebäude ein wirklicher
heldentat hat den schützen ramos dann
erschossen auch mit hilfe weiterer
beamten die ihm zu hilfe gekommen sind
der mann wurde selbst verletzt ist aber
okay da zumindest war dann dieses
attentat ist er aber glaubt vorbei und
dann begann bekam eben diese
dramatischen szenen dieser eltern die
ihm wie man ja sieht in den videos sie
zur schule laufen die nicht wissen was
mit ihren kindern ist die dann
umgeleitet worden zu diesem civic center
das ist eine art kleines chaos hier und
dort eben auf informationen gewartet
haben und viele kinder und das habe ich
auch selbst als ich vor zehn jahren
gekauft habe selbst gesehen viele eltern
nehmen ihre kinder in empfang sie sind
am leben ist sie haben sie überstanden
und da gibt es eben die eltern sie sehen
ihre kinder nicht die kommen nicht raus
sind nicht da die zur beginnenden der
krankenhäuser anzurufen es ist das sind
wirklich emotionale furchtbare
schreckliche szenen menschen die sich
dann um arme die beine da die ganze
stadt 2-führung ist hier spürbar und
genau das hat sich abgespielt in den
stunden nach her natürlich jetzt weiß
man die wahrscheinliche endgültige
opferbilanz 19 tote kinder im alter
zwischen sieben und elf jahren es ist so
grauenvoll es ist nicht vorstellbar was
weiß man werden wir gerade gesehen über
dieses monster über diesen jungen mann
18 jahre als der das angerichtet hat er
all diese kinder ermordet hat er stammt
aus nord dakota ist hier in novalja
aufgewachsen zur schule gegangen es gibt
bereits erste berichten dass er
möglicherweise die highschool
abgebrochen hätte das eher geduldet
worden wäre es gibt auch die berichte
dass er auch vor die tat praktisch
kryptisch auf instagram angekündigt hat
gegenüber einer person ja gar nicht
kannte die hat er gezeigt mit einem post
wo er als waffen gezeigt hat zwei sturm
wäre und dann mit dieser frau einen
dialog begonnen habe wo er gesagt hat
ich habe ein kleines geheimnis und sehr
gesagt was ist es denn ich werde es dir
sagen und dann so getan hat als würde
die antwort kommen um 11 uhr und dann
kurz nach elf gegen die schießerei los
als das sehr unheimlich sehr kryptisch
alters arbeitet die polizei natürlich
auch er hat wie gesagt auch sich selbst
gepostet vor dem attentat und wie gesagt
auch ein munitions magazin gezeigt und
eben diese beiden sturmgewehre man muss
dazu sagen er hat diese sturmgewehre
genau an seinem geburtstag gekauft als
er 18 jahre alt wurde tut mit diesem
alter darf man in amerika waffen kaufen
was eigentlich schon ein wenig absurd
ist wenn man bedenkt dass man erst mit
21 jahren in amerika ein bier trinken
darf wie gesagt das weiß man bisher über
ihn natürlich man wird in den nächsten
minuten stunden und tagen wirklich sehr
viel erfahren über diesen diesem jungen
mann ihr das monster eigentlich und
natürlich auch versuchen zusammen zu
nehmen was waren wirklich seine motive
warum hat er das getan hat ist eine
unfassbare tat und man wird natürlich
wissen wollen in amerika und im rest der
welt was diesen mann getrieben hat daher
wird sagt es ist eine wirklich
unfassbare tat und du stehst jetzt ja
gerade vor dieser grundschule wo eben
dieses massaker stattgefunden hat
hattest du schon die möglichkeit
bedeuten vor ort zu sprechen vielleicht
mit angehörigen oder menschen die eben
ja vor ort waren
ja es ist jetzt mit mir in der nacht
hier kurz nach 2 uhr ortszeit die
einzigen menschen die jetzt hier sind
sind da polizisten die den tatort
bewachen und natürlich medienvertreter
die jetzt praktisch im minutentakt hier
ankommen das ist sicher eine der größten
medien geschichten in den in den usa in
diesem jahr oder zumindest bis bisher
das sind die aktivitäten ich war selbst
kurz bei diesem city center dort ist
niemand mehr die leute sind nach hause
gegangen aber natürlich wird erwartet
dass wenn die sonne hier aufgeht viele
eltern jetzt hier wieder zurückkommen
oder viele eltern auch beginnen wieder
die suche aufzunehmen nach ihren kindern
es sind jetzt bisher sieben bis acht
dieser kinder identifiziert und man hat
natürlich sofort diese fotos publiziert
und alleine diesen fotos sind einfach so
erschütternd und eine anklage eigentlich
gegen diesen diesen teenager diesen
jungen mann der offensichtlich völlig
verwirrt war ein richtiges richtiges
monster der hier so ein unglaubliches
unheil angerichtet hat dass das diesen
ort natürlich diese kleinstadt ganz
amerika und die ganze welt erschüttert
was ist das für eine kleinstadt
beschreibt das juwel wie diese
kleinstadt von nehmen zuvor noch nie
gehört hat mitten in texas in einem jahr
schon sehr konservativen bundesstaat in
den usa
habe ich gesorgt so eine kleinstadt im
westen von texas wenn man hier von zehn
toten wird durch die steppe dann durch
die eder durch diese weiten ebenen die
man in texas camp kommt man eben hierher
in dieser stadt ganz normale stadt mit
mit hotels mit walmart mit mit mit
häusern mit einem kleinen stadtkern also
nichts nichts besonderes recht ruhig
verschlafen eigentlich und jetzt
natürlich diese unfassbare szenen es ist
eine sehr spanische stadt 80 prozent
einwohner sind hispanic natürlich die
stadt ist auch nahe liegt auch nahe der
mexikanischen grenze
einfach ein normaler ort im westen texas
wie man wie man es kennt hier eine ganze
nation ist jetzt gelähmt vor schmerz die
flagge vor dem weißen haus sie hängt auf
halbmast
ein kind zu verlieren fühlt sich so an
als wären einem ein stück der eigenen
seele geraubt das sagte us präsident joe
biden und er weiß wovon er spricht denn
auch er musste seinen sohn beau zu grabe
tragen der an einem hirntumor gestorben
war der präsident war sichtlich
erschüttert als er vor die kameras trat
und strengere waffengesetze forderte
ein hub
ich hatte gehofft als ich präsident
wurde dass ich das nicht noch einmal nur
ein weiter das massaker in texas in der
grundschule junge unschuldige 2
[Musik]
die vielen kleinen kinder die mit erlebt
haben was passiert in schulverbünden
die ihre freunde sterben sahen als wären
sie auf einem schlachtfeld um himmels
willen
das wird sie für den rest ihres lebens
verfolgen
die eltern ihre kinder nie wieder sehen
werden sie werden nie mit ihnen ins bett
bringen können und pushen können
die eltern werden nie wieder dieselben
sein
ein user firma es ist als würde ihnen
ein stück ihrer seele weggerissen werden
da ist unglaubliche lehre in deiner
brust es fühlt sich so an als würde man
hinein gesagt als ob man da nie wieder
herauskommen kann ersticken es wird nie
mehr so wie vorher
heute abend hätte ich die nation für sie
zu berichten
gibt den eltern und geschwistern die
kraft in der dunkelheit
inflation müssen wir uns fragen liegen
in gottes namen wir der waffenlobbyist
die stirn bieten werden wir tun das
gefühl wir wissen dass es getan werden
ich habe es satt wir müssen handeln und
sagen sie mir nicht dass wir keinen
einfluss auf dieses gemessen haben
können das ist in den montag
unser gebet heute abend es waren diese
eltern
die im rebellen scheinen sie schlagen
werde ich wieder schlafen können
was sage ich in meinen anderen kinder
was ist
unglaublich emotionale rede vom us
präsidenten
schärfere waffengesetze das ist beides
ganz wichtiges thema bereits im
wahlkampf doch die waffenlobby die ist
mächtig in den usa und ihre publica im
kongress ebenso jetzt schauen wir noch
mal auf diesen ort an dem diese grausame
tat begangen wurde eine grundschule im
us bundesstaat texas in der kleinen
stadt wie verdi ja jeden menschen in
texas in den usa und auf der ganzen welt
berührt dieser schreckliche amoklauf
zutiefst auch diesen basketball trainer
trennen da wendet sich coach steve kerr
vor der partie seiner various in texas
in einer emotionalen botschaft an die
politik in washington
ich werde heute nicht über basketball
reden seitdem ende unseres aufwärmens
wurden über 14 kinder und ein lehrer
ermordet 600 kilometer von hier
erlitt eine tiefe
vor zehn tagen hausen alte schwarze
menschen in einem supermarkt in buffalo
ermordet südkalifornien waren es
asiatische kirchgänger und jungen wurden
kinder in der schule ermordet
wann werden wir endlich was unternehmen
anteil an total ich bin es leid ich bin
es so leid hierher zu kommen ist und den
am boden zerstörten familien mein
mitgefühl auszudrücken ich bin die
ausreden leid ich bin die
schweigeminuten so leid
da draußen sind 50 senatoren ihr es
ablehnen einem gesetz zur überprüfung
von waffenbesitzern zuzustimmen vor
jahren wurde es vom repräsentantenhaus
verabschiedet und liegt jetzt seit zwei
jahren rum und es gibt einen grund wieso
die senatoren das nicht tun um an der
macht zu bleiben
ich frage sie also
um ihre gier nach macht zu stillen
weiter die leben unserer kinder unserer
alten und unserer kirchgänger denn genau
danach sieht es aus denn genau das
machen sie jede woche
ich habe es satt mir reicht's
50 senatoren in washington die es
ablehnen diesen waffenbesitzer
überprüfungen die 90 prozent der
amerikaner wollen die senatoren halten
uns gerade als geiseln sie werden nicht
zustimmen weil sie sich an ihre macht
klammern wollen
es ist lächerlich mir reicht's
mit diesen worten spricht er ganz ganz
vielen menschen aus der seele seinem
achtzehnten geburtstag hat der täter
einfach so sich die waffen besorgen
können mit denen er dann all diese
kinder am morgen
während auch der erfolgreichste nba
spielers curry äußerte sich zutiefst
betroffen zu dieser tat
es ist irgendwie schwer sich darauf zu
konzentrieren basketball zu spielen um
zu wissen was in diesem staat passiert
ist und ich habe kinder die jeden tag
zur schule schicken und sie dort
abliefere und man fühlte und fühlt mit
den eltern die durch machen was sie
durchmachen müssen ich kann mir den
schmerz nicht einmal vorstellen ich
nehme die herausforderung an einen weg
zu finden aber meine stimme und meine
plattform zu nutzen um hoffentlich etwas
zu verändern ist das leben bis zum
ungleichgewicht es ist schwer das in
perspektive zu bringen man nutzt also
seine routine um sich vorzubereiten ist
und natürlich schweifen die gedanken von
zeit zu zeit ab vor allem im moment der
stille vor dem spiel und so weiter es
ist also hart
daran mich gesegnet wir sind was wir tun
können was wir tun
dass wir uns nicht zweieinhalb stunden
lang in einem basketball spiel verlieren
können wisst ihr auch wenn es schwierig
ist
in unserem land
das schreckliche massaker passiert es
ist unser bild reporter herbert
bauernebel herbert was kannst du uns
genaueres zudem tat vorgang sagen
die polizei um das sind auch viele
bundes kräfte dabei wfp und etf sind
natürlich nach wie vor dabei genau
festzustellen wie dieses massaker
abgelaufen ist was man bisher weiß ist
dass der schütze salvador ramos 18 jahre
alt aus der der gerade noch in die
highschool hier gegangen ist begonnen
hat mit dem amoklauf mit einem schuss
attentat auf seine eigene großmutter ist
dann mit einem pickup-truck
losgefahren hat sogar einen unfall
gebaut am weg zur schule wurde dann von
den polizisten dann aber noch weiter
fahren er dürfte weiter
weitergehen
offensichtlich auch das wird jetzt
untersucht werden ist bei der schule
eingetroffen und hat begonnen hier herum
zu schießen nicht eingedrungen ist dann
vom klassenzimmer zu klassenzimmer
gegangen und hat ist es unfassbare
massaker angerichtet offensichtlich mit
einem sturmgewehr hatte auch eine
schusssichere weste dabei hatte gross im
munitions magazine die leider hier auch
in den usa üblich sind man muss jetzt
genau schauen wie groß wie viele kugeln
da drinnen waren das wird untersucht und
am ende dann doch eine heldentat eines
office der border patrol der ohne auch
viel rückendeckung zu warten in die
schule eingedrungen ist der schütze
hatte sich da bereits verbarrikadiert
hat und dem beamten ist es gelungen ihn
zu töten um das massaker praktisch zu
beenden danach natürlich ganz
frenetische furchtbare szenen einerseits
eltern die zur schule gelaufen sind
andererseits natürlich der abtransport
der opfer viele bereits tot es gibt im
bericht dass zweier kinder eingeliefert
wurden ins krankenhaus und bereits
verstorben waren am ende natürlich wie
man jetzt weiß 19 kinder umgekommen
einem alter zwischen sieben und elf
jahren und jetzt beginnen die ersten
identifikationen herauszukommen in der
nacht die ersten namen die ersten
gesichter die ersten fotos und das
natürlich ist eine stumme anklage gegen
dieses mal sind verbrechen und auch
natürlich gegen die politiker in amerika
die es einfach nicht fertig bringt den
gebrauch von schusswaffen hier doch
einzudämmen und die gesetze zu
verschärfen
das heißt wer den täter und ein
mögliches motiv ist es bereits bekannt
geworden
es gibt
anhaltspunkte und und gerüchte und auch
geschichten man muss jetzt sehen was
wirklich dran ist es gibt einen bericht
wo eben gesagt wurde dass er in seiner
schule möglicherweise gemobbt worden
wäre das könnte ein grund sein was man
weiß ist dass er auf instagram ganz
kryptisch diese tat praktisch
angekündigt hat er hat fotos gepostet
von den sturmgewehren die er gekauft hat
an seinem 18 geburtstag er hat ein foto
gepostet wo ein munitions magazin in
seinem schoß liegt und hat eine an
unbekannte junge frau hier getagt bei
diesem fonds und dann mit ihr eine eine
unterhaltung begonnen er hat gesagt er
würde es gerne anvertrauen er hat zu
getan ich habe eine überraschung hatte
er gesagt aus sie hat sich erkundigt was
das wäre und er sagt es soll ja sie
solle warten bis 11 uhr wäre und kurz
nach 11 uhr hat dieses massaker begonnen
all das wird jetzt genau untersucht dass
die die natürlich der ganze internet
verkehrt seine kommunikation wird
durchforstet werden es ist anzunehmen
dass die polizei hier nach nach handy
sucht nach computer nach festplatten
dass man hier genau sieht welche
vergangenheit dieser mann hat und was
natürlich die motive sein können dann
darüber ist jetzt eine große diskussion
losgebrochen was hat diesen jungen mann
selbst 18 jahre selbst fast noch ein
kind dazu getrieben so ein unfassbares
verbrechen anzurichten hier in dieser in
dieser kleinen idyllischen stadt in
texas daher werde sagt es ist wirklich
ein unfassbares verbrechen in einer
solch kleinen stadt du bist steht es
jetzt gerade vor dieser grundschule es
ist mitten in der nacht bei dir
vielleicht kannst du mal einmal uns
trotzdem mitnehmen was ist das für ein
ort wo sich eben dieses dieser amoklauf
passiert ist aber
es ist einer dieser typischen
kleinstädte die es so viele gibt in
amerika natürlich aufgrund der tatsache
dass weil die sehr nahe an der
mexikanischen grenze liegt ist es sehr
sehr latino hier sehr spanisch sprechen
die meisten großen bevölkerung spricht
hier spanisch dass das ist das eine zum
anderen eine ganz normale
stadt kleinstadt in texas mit einem
großen shopping zentrum mit einem markt
mit einer kirche natürlich mit einem mit
kleinen häusern ruhig ein ruhiges leben
eigentlich wahrscheinlich viele junge
menschen werden sich wahrscheinlich
denken etwas langweilig aber den
menschen hier scheint ist hier zu
gefallen und deshalb ist es auch so
unfassbar dass so ein unglaubliches blut
verbrechen als ein derartiges massaker
in einer so idyllischen kleinen stab
vivaldi stattfinden hat können und
gleichzeitig hier ist jetzt wieder die
diskussion angerollt herbert über
strengere waffengesetze in den usa
werden auch die emotionale rede von
us-präsident beiden hier verfolgen
können der sich seit dem wahlkampf dafür
einsetzt und man fragt sich hierzulande
woran liegt das wie viel macht hat da
der us-präsident warum geht das nicht
voran
naja man muss man muss hier vorsichtig
sein um nicht ganz typisch und zu werden
bei diesem wenn man diesen politischen
vorgänge hier in den usa beschreibt denn
klar ist es gab diesen moment vor fast
zehn jahren sandy hoch in connecticut
ein wahnsinniger namens rm lancer hat
hier 20 erstklässler kinder im alter von
sechs jahren mit einem sturmgewehr
massakriert ganz amerika sagte wenn das
nicht der anlass wäre die waffengesetze
zu verschärfen dann würde das für immer
scheitern es ist gescheiter damals und
es hat sich nichts geändert die
erklärung dafür liegt in der
amerikanischen politik um die
waffengesetze zu verschärfen braucht man
eine 60-prozentige stimmen mehrheit im
senat und das ist de facto unmöglich
denn das land ist politisch komplett
gespalten der senat selbst derzeit mit
50 zu 50 senatoren genau in der mitte
gespalten um die waffengesetze zu
verschärfen würde es eine
überparteiliche anstrengungen bedürfen
und da dafür gibt es einfach keinen
appetit in amerika war das land einfach
zu gestalten ist und wir reden hier
nicht einmal von trust eine verschärfung
der waffengesetze
gesetzesinitiativen die am tisch legen
sind eher kleinere dinge wie zum
beispiel die verstärkung der an von
background checks von überprüfungen das
schließen von schlupflöchern wie zb den
verkauf von waffen bei waffen schoss
alles eigentlich ganz normale
hausverstand mäßige initiativen aber
auch selbst werden nicht durchgebracht
werden die waffenlobby
spendet sehr viel geld an politiker
besonders an die republikaner und auch
ohne diesen geld ist amerika der zog
polarisiert dass es einfach keine
übereinkunft geben kann keine
übereinstimmung zwischen den parteien um
mir endlich einen sich einen ruck zu
geben und zu sagen wir müssen hier etwas
tun endlich
vielen dank herbert bauernebel mit den
aktuellen informationen auswahl die in
texas in den usa wo eben dieser schlimme
amoklauf gestern passiert ist dann
gehämmert